the attitude is it's on you
for getting the virus it's on you nfl
team whichever team it is 49ers raiders
whatever for having a guy who gets it
as they continue to send all these guys
out in the communities where the numbers
are going through the roof
yeah right so so there's a randomness to
this it's not always
fault what you're what they're doing is
they're making teams
pay the price for the inherent flaws
in the nfl's process everyone's going
home at night and possibly getting it
yep
everyone's coming back and giving a
sample in the morning
right that we don't know until the next
day whether or not it was positive yeah
so the guy's in the building with
everyone else he's on the practice field
with everyone else he's on the sidelines
with everyone else on game day for guys
who test deposit on game day
that's where i don't like it because it
introduces
a randomness that has teams
fall victim to this lack of preparation
or being short-handed for a game
and they really didn't do anything wrong
yeah no i i mean
you're right it's it's hard to avoid at
this point
unless you're being you know listen like
you said you're going to charity events
and some building and something like
that then hey
you know you get it i you know hey i
don't feel that sorry for you
i don't know what to say yeah you're
you're talking the line of being
reckless and stupid in those type of
situations but but you say
i did i did but you think that's the
right way to say what is the right
thing what is it that's it
that's it got it yeah that's the one i
keep messing up yeah just stick with the
t
and two vowels leave out any other
concepts okay thank you either way
i guess that's why they have to take
these extreme measures though right mike
i mean i don't i don't know
this is why trent williams and brandon
iuke even though
they're not positive for the test and uh
yeah the they you know we're in close
contact
i think that's probably what the nfl is
doing one they're worried about
hey we want to make sure the game
happens like you're saying they want to
get that done
and they know it might take a few days
before oh if we found out somebody else
was positive or whatever it might happen
and then it spreads through the football
team
but i guess that's why they have to take
these extreme measures for guys that are
not positive too because of the things
you said about
the randomness off the field and
everything like that to where we just
don't know yet
and i guess they're being extra careful
as much as it stinks for the 49ers that
trent williams and ayuk
you know are not are not playing
what else is the nfl supposed to do i
mean what
is the nfl oh roll the dice and let them
in the facility
and then all of a sudden we find out one
of them is positive and now there's 20
other guys positive so
that's where it's a really tough one
there and and uh i can't really fault
the nfl a whole lot for what they have
in this situation
until you have a bubble or something
like that right
and then it could be different well the
only way to ensure
equity for all teams would have been to
put the teams in a home market bubble
to limit the opportunities to catch it
when you're away
from the facility and and see that's the
thing
there have been people who have gotten
this even though they've dotted every
eye and crossed every t and done
everything they were supposed to do to
avoid it
you know not every infection and
exposure
is the result of carelessness or
negligence
and i guess the message is and if
if you're an nfl team coach gm owner
team president whoever anyone in a
position of authority the message to the
entire organization
is this the nfl is is basically applying
a strict liability standard
they don't care how any of our people
get it all they care is
did somebody test positive on a day
where they gave the sample
were at work and potentially they were
in contact with other people
if yes then whoever they were in
sufficiently close contact with is
getting shut down even if they never
got it and so we are
in an even more important position of
having to do everything we can
to avoid being exposed to it which means
choosing to stay in a hotel
which means at your house
splitting it into sections where
the guy who's playing football stays
here
and everybody else stays there and you
just talk through facetime
or something yeah right you never get in
the same room with each other
that those are the kind of measures for
the teams
down the stretch that want to avoid this
i mean think about it
for the 49ers yeah tonight and we'll
talk about this in a second whether or
not they have a snowball's chance in
hell against the packers
but you know this is a loss that
potentially it
will move them one closer to one loss
too many yeah
and you know not that not that we
thought they were going to turn it
around and make it to the playoffs
anyway
but when you're four and four and it can
go either way and the first game
you get this curveball thrown at your
head and you go to four and five
and you feel like it happens under
circumstances that weren't appropriate
you know it makes it even harder for
kyle shanahan to hold everything
together chris yeah no
it does i mean it's more of a gonna be a
lesson again for i think other teams in
football
just again to be like whoa we got to be
careful here i mean this could
you know this this could ruin it though
this could ruin the whole season for the
49ers
i mean it really can and it also can be
a great advantage i mean
think about the packers right now a team
that's reeling a little bit
what they've lost two out of the last
three and
they got to go to san francisco a place
where they got whooped last year i mean
whooped both tied twice yes yeah i mean
totally dominated and they don't match
up well with them
as is even this year but now man you're
gonna get to go there
and fortunately your team's done
everything right or got lucky and
avoided the virus and you're gonna get
to play this football game
and yeah play a much less than 49ers
football team here to kind of jump start
your game there so i mean that's
that to me is the thing that i think
players are going to continue to look at
especially
you know the teams that are in the race
right now where they're gonna
have these incentives to hopefully be
very strict
and not be stupid outside the facility
you know i don't think it's gonna be
realistic to
block off the house for these guys like
you're saying but i do think they'll try
their best to avoid restaurants or doing
anything like that
and uh i i sure as hell like to think at
this point they're doing their best to
avoid restaurants chris i've been i've
been a restaurant since march right
right and and and i don't have a
professional athlete career hinging on
my
ability to stay away from the virus i
mean i i'd like to not catch it i don't
want to roll the dice
uh i've got a couple of other factors
that make me concerned that i could have
a bad outcome so
yeah i don't want it but still you're
not giving up much
right yeah you go listen one thing i've
learned over the last seven months of
not going to restaurants is
i really didn't need to go to
restaurants it's kind of nice
yeah but i don't need it right right you
can get them to even bring it to your
house yeah yeah
right it's a you know it's a spoil of
life to be able to go to the restaurant
get away you're right but it's not like
a necessity or anything like that and
yeah i would like to think to what
you're saying
you know i know we've had this
conversation earlier this week if i was
playing quarterback and football right
now
i don't even know if my kids would be in
school anything i i'd probably be
keeping them all home and just going
sorry this is the way life is right now
it's too important for daddy's career
and it's too important for the rest of
your life because daddy's making a lot
of money and it's going to help out the
rest of your life so you're staying at
home
at the kitchen table and look into the
ipad and zoom it up here kid
i mean that's what i would be saying if
i was still playing
well and and these are the measures that
players need to understand they must
consider
given the way that the nfl is dealing
with it
is it fair does it matter this is the
way it's going to be the alternative is
home market bubble or don't play
this is the only way that they can do it
safely this is their way of dealing with
the inherent flaws in the system the
incubation period
and the lag time between sample
collection and the arrival of the result
those are things the nfl at least is
acknowledged in a roundabout way
it can't crack so it has to
it has to come up with a hack around it
and that's what they've done and that's
why the game's going forward tonight and
look
part of it let's let's just let's be
real we always are
there's a financial motive yeah yeah
they don't want to start missing games
and having to pay back the networks or
and even if money wouldn't be paid back
it's definitely become
something that has to be dealt with in
the ongoing relationship they don't want
to do that they don't want to be in that
position so meanwhile
the networks just have to take it
and look this is not i'm not being
critical here i'm just saying this is
the way it is
fox tonight they're getting a game where
it's 18 versus b
team yeah and this is a far less
attractive game now no definitely
definitely and uh yeah yeah you know but
hey any given thursday
right who knows what will happen paul
allen was on pftpm yesterday and he
follows the packers very closely because
they're in the vikings division and they
play twice a year
he said the vikings did to the packers
what the 49ers did to packers twice last
year with the running
he sensed that there were guys on the
packers defense that just weren't
bringing it the way that they should
right speaks to the lack of energy that
aaron rodgers noticed last week
and maybe there's a way to catch the
packers napping oh maybe the packers
think they just show up and win this
game
and they get hit in the mouth early and
they realize it's not going to be quite
so easy
listen i i you know before the covet 19
stuff here
i i was very seriously going i'm not so
sure i'm not going to take the 49ers
here
i i was not like oh definitely going
with green bay because they got two more
you know two more wins than the 49ers at
this point or two less losses whatever
that is
you know but yeah there is some real
issues here with the match-up the nfl is
a match-up league
and as we've seen the packers they can't
stop the run
against good running football teams i
mean that's just the the simple facts of
the matter
and shanahan with his ability to run
and then the knowledge he has of mike
pettin because they were on the same
staff this is where he can be dangerous
you know this is why he was dangerous
against them last year
because i'm sure he knew oh if i get him
in this formation or this and that
he likes to play this defense and oh man
do i got something for
him when he does that oh bam george
kittle you know corner post 70 yard
touchdown oh
raheem modester down the sideline
untouched for 45 yard touchdown runs
so there is something to look at tonight
where i do give the 49ers hope one
because they still got some good
football players on the field
two shanahan is creative but i just
don't know if they can overcome it now
i don't i think it's just it's a few too
many players
and then no practice or walkthroughs or
being in the building yesterday i just
don't think i could
actually pick the 49ers as much as i
think they have a chance to pull off an
upset tonight
that's where an extra few days would
have really really would have right
shanahan not in so far as maybe you get
trent williams and brandon iuke back but
you get a little more time to cook up
something that you can implement that
you can teach right that your guys can
go out and try to knock off the package
but i'm with you
this sets up as a potential surprise for
green bay
look they've been dreadful their last
three games
in california and it's glaring because
they otherwise have been so damn good
right last year they were 13-3 in the
regular season 13 and four if you
add in the playoffs one loss at home
a close one a flukey one to the eagles
on a thursday night
three losses in california
and ugly losses in california to a
non-playoff chargers team
in a building where the packers overran
the stadium packers fans overran the
stadium
and two losses to the 49ers and remember
we had zadaria smith with us at the
super bowl and he was at a loss to
explain what happened and he admitted
they don't have energy they don't have
juice
there's there's there's a defect there
somewhere somehow
and we we talked about this on football
pod in america yesterday
because i was pressing tony dungey and
rodney harrison
to help me understand when aaron rodgers
says there's a lack of energy who's
who's he calling out
yeah rodney says it's the defensive
leadership
that is laying down on the job that
isn't getting it done
and coach dungey said in indianapolis
when peyton manning's around you never
hear a thing about a lack of energy
right so you know you got a shell game
here
yeah coach quarterback defensive leaders
right somebody's not properly putting a
foot in the ass
of the green bay packers defense at the
worst possible times right and maybe
that happens again tonight yeah
i mean it could it certainly can well
it's hard
to have like that energy sometimes and
the things that rodney's talking about
because i agree with
you know rodney and i understand what he
said and i understand what coach is
saying too
but where i'll say like you know the
packers don't win the physical battle a
lot
and when you don't win the physical
battle a lot it's hard to be the team of
energy
because you're always going oh we kind
of need the game to go this way
and then the show ended oh we're up by
10. oh this is when we get energy
because we got pass rushers and we got a
lot of good cover guys
and now we're ready we got energy now
we're up by ten but wait
it's still seven seven and you can run
and throw
oh no we know we we lose our energy
because they start to get physically
beat up
and then on offense you know hey aaron
jones are not they're a good running
offense
but they're not a great running offense
you know they're a borderline really
good to great running offense because of
number 12 at quarterback
and what he does and he opens the field
up for the run game and always gets them
in the right plays and things like that
to where he he is responsible for the
energy on offense
almost always he really is and i say he
i mean aaron rodgers
so you know i just don't know if you can
fix some of the problems they have
they're still going to be good they're
going to be in the playoffs they're
going to be a
pain in the butt to get them out of the
playoffs but that's because of number
12.
you know i don't know if their team as
we've talked about
i i don't know if i look at it as super
bowl caliber i
i look at it as playoff caliber with a
super bowl quarterback where
maybe if you get the right matchups in
the playoffs they can get to the super
bowl
and do some damage there and we'll see
but i think there's a handful of
matchups in the nfc and
any team that you know plays the packers
where it's just not good for them and
you know that's where i i worry about
them a little bit
you mentioned aaron jones he's
officially questionable for tonight's
game with a calf injury he wasn't
downgraded yesterday which means he made
the trip and he's in play and they need
him because jamal
williams yeah is on the cover 19 reserve
lifts the packers had the issue earlier
this week
because aj dillon one of the running
backs tested positive on sunday
to your point about the defense yeah
this is something rodney mentioned
yesterday and this is something i
noticed when i rewatched the game
earlier this week
because shereen williams and i do a
re-watch every tuesday and it was that
game
there's a moment where and we always
talk about how the x's and o's and it
looks good until it's time to go do it
there's a moment where erv smith vikings
tight end
neutralizes convincingly preston smith
right
packers linebacker to blow a hole wide
open for dalvin cook
that shouldn't happen chris it
definitely shouldn't
no you know there there's there's issues
as far as
physicality for them in the run game and
then there's issues for them
schematically a little too
at times and where you know the
positions they're put in but the biggest
problem they have
is they just don't have run stoppers
they don't
kenny clark is is good i think he's a
little overrated i'm not gonna lie i
think green bay
paid him a little too much but i
understand that they dropped him the
first round
he's been pretty consistently good
throughout his career
but other than that mike they just don't
have anybody else who's capable
of either one clogging holes and
creating a mosh pit
or two just shooting through gaps
and creating disruption that way they
have nothing on the inside that way
and you know i think it's something
they're gonna have to continue to toy
with
as they go go here because maybe maybe
they're a team that goes hey the hell
with it we don't play defensive tackles
we got kenny clark
and we got preston smith and we got you
know rashaan gary who they drafted in
the first round two years ago and
president
maybe they just go the linebacker kind
of new england route and they move
people around and try to confuse you
you don't know who's coming who's going
but i do think
it's worth toying with because when they
do try to play straight up and physical
they never win those battles and to
further underscore the risks in all nfl
communities the packers have announced
that they will have no
no fans at home games for the
foreseeable future in the interest of
the safety of the community in wisconsin
one of the areas now where the virus is
raging out of control
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports